[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE ABRAMS: Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
CAMERON MYLER: Thank you.
TRACY EVANS: Thanks
for having us.
MIKE ABRAMS: So let's
start with your sports.
You both are in fairly
uncommon sports.
How did you initially get
involved in luging and flipping
multiple times in the air
on skis at an early age
to become an Olympian?
CAMERON MYLER: OK.
So I grew up close to Lake
Placid in upstate New York,
and my parents volunteered
at the Olympics in 1980
at the luge track.
So I'd been skiing already,
and I went with my parents
to see luge every day.
So I saw the best athletes
in the world competing,
and Lake Placid is
a really small town
so I kind of got the
Olympic bug and saw other--
I saw figure skating
and hockey and I
saw Eric Heiden win his medals.
So I was, like, all
excited about the Olympics.
And after the games there
was a two-week luge camp,
so my parents let me skip
school and go to luge camp.
I got on a sled, loved it
from the very first time,
and at the end of the two weeks
I won the Junior Olympics race
in my age group, and that
was kind of the beginning
of the next 18 years on a sled.
MIKE ABRAMS: And how old
were you when you first
went to luge camp?
TRACY EVANS: Really?
You're going to ask me that now?
MIKE ABRAMS: No, when
you went to luge camp.
[LAUGHTER]
TRACY EVANS: Luge camp.
MIKE ABRAMS: When you started.
CAMERON MYLER: Yes.
I was 11.
MIKE ABRAMS: 11.
CAMERON MYLER: I was 11.
Which is pretty typical.
So in luge there are
like a dozen or so tracks
around the world, and you
don't get very many runs
on each track every year.
So it really takes
years to be good
and to be successful
internationally.
So 10 or 11 is pretty typical
for jumping on a sled.
MIKE ABRAMS: 10 or 11.
Wow.
And what about you?
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Well, it's kind of a
family affair in our house.
So my brother was
actually an aerialist
on the US ski team
for many years, way
before I got into it.
I was 21 when I actually
got into the sport,
so a little bit later.
But yeah.
So my brother was in it, and
I was actually at school,
going to school down at
Florida State University.
And-- yep.
A lot of good skiing
down that way.
[LAUGHTER]
But, you know, there
wasn't a lot athletically
for me to get involved
in down there.
I was actually riding horses
and doing gymnastics growing up
a ton, and both my
brother and I skied
since we could walk, come from
a very, very avid skiing family.
But anyway-- so I decided
I was either going
to take a semester off and
go to Winter Park Colorado
and ski where my brother was
skiing with a freestyle club
there, or I was transferring
to University of New Hampshire
where there was an
equestrian riding team.
So I first went to Winter
Park, went out there, always
thought I'd be a bump
skier, a mogul skier.
My brother did aerials.
I thought he was nuts.
There is no way I would
have ever done that.
So anyway, I went out.
And with freestyle you
usually do all the events
at a regional level.
So I did, and actually
did the best in aerials.
So obviously I didn't
transfer to UNH.
I ended up coming
out to Salt Lake City
and training with
a coach out there,
and basically I was
the only woman training
with five other men out there,
and it took a little convincing
for the coach to even
let me come and train.
So, yeah.
So it's been kind of--
then I was on, basically,
about 12 years on the US team.
MIKE ABRAMS: So what
was that training
like, from when you
first started to right
before your first Olympics?
What was the schedule
like, and the effort that
goes into becoming one of
the best in your sports
in the world?
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Do you want to--
CAMERON MYLER: Sure.
TRACY EVANS: Go ahead.
CAMERON MYLER: I can start.
So I was on the national
team for 14 years, and--
I think Tracy will
probably agree--
competing on the
level that we did
is basically a full-time job.
So the off-season is when
most of the really intense
physical training takes place.
So for luge there are
kind of two components.
And it's the start,
which is the only chance
that you have to
accelerate the sled,
and then once you pull
off from the handles--
and you wear spikes on your
fingertips-- paddle down
the ramp, and then you lie down
and then it's all about skill
and how well you
can drive the lines.
So in the summertime we would do
a lot of sort of basic training
at first, and then
it's all about sort
of power and quickness
and speed on the start.
So a lot of upper body,
back, core work, and a lot
of Olympic lifting
in the summertime.
And then in the
winter we would be
on the road from usually
the beginning of October
until December.
So usually 10 weeks in the fall.
You'd come home for,
like, a week at Christmas.
And it was kind of enough
time to wash your clothes,
eat a couple of meals
that your mom made,
and then back on the road
for another eight weeks
for the World Cup and
world championship season.
So definitely kind
of year-round.
And I was able to
work, actually,
undergrad into that schedule
because I went to Dartmouth
and it had--
it's on quarters, so I would go
with the luge team in the fall
and winter and then
I'd go to school
in the spring and summer.
I was there for a little
longer than four years.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
So for aerials, basically
it starts on a trampoline.
And there are hours and
hours of refining your skills
for doing backflips and
twists and multiple twists
and multiple flips
and all of that.
And you're in a big
harness as well, which
has a spinning belt. So
that's attached to ropes.
So there's a lot of--
trampoline training is a
really, really big facet of it.
Then you actually transfer
it to water ramping,
where you're coming down--
Lake Placid and Park City have
two water ramp facilities.
And you come down the
ramps on plastic surface,
go off, and land into
a big swimming pool
with all your skis, your boots.
You know, you have
a life jacket on.
Usually you have a dry suit
or a wet suit, and a helmet,
of course.
And I've always
had the question,
do your ski boots get wet.
And I'm like,
yeah, they get wet.
[LAUGHTER]
And we break skis and
all sorts of things.
And water does hurt.
It's a great way to train.
That's where you-- like I said,
there's a very long process
in taking what you see on snow--
there's a qualification
process for every single jump
that you do on snow.
So you have to do it a
certain number of times,
you have to qualify it in
front of a US team coach safely
five times in a
row, and then you're
able to transfer it on to
snow once the season starts.
And then I think-- like
what Cameron said--
I think one of
the misconceptions
about Olympic athletes is
that the only thing they
train for and compete
in are the Olympics.
And we have a World
Cup circuit that we
are on every single year.
And so you go--
CAMERON MYLER: You
may not see our sports
except at the Olympics on TV.
TRACY EVANS: Right.
Yeah.
Right.
And we have world
championships every other year.
So we were on tour from
December all the way
to April every year, and
then our summer training also
we would do trampoline starting
in May through October.
So we had a little bit of time
off in April and a little bit
of time off in
October, but other
than that it was year-round
training for sure.
MIKE ABRAMS: Yeah.
And so you obviously did a
lot of the trampoline training
and all these things.
Have you seen the
training evolve
from when you started doing
it your first couple of years
to where we are today with the
technology and the advancements
that have happened?
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Well, I know for aerials--
you know, I think the
water ramp facility
itself has become better.
The jumps that we used
to use for water ramping
were not as similar as the jumps
that we now create on snow,
but now they are
very, very similar.
So that transition
from water to snow
is not nearly as different.
And really the only thing that
you have to modify for on snow
is the landing hill,
because we obviously
land on a very, very
steep landing hill,
and water you're
landing pretty much--
you really don't try to
land straight up and down,
but we try to land with our
tips going into the water.
But aside from
that, there's still
tons of trampoline training.
And I don't think that there's--
I think where, at
least for aerials,
it's changed is
more time on snow.
The more time that we can
actually train on snow--
so more training camps have
come about where we've been able
to--
where the team's been able
to be on snow more often.
CAMERON MYLER: So
with luge the--
it's hard to see when
you watch it on TV
or even when you're
standing at the track
and a sled goes by
at 90 miles an hour,
but the sled is-- there's
a lot of technology that
goes into the sled.
So a single sled-- and
women just do singles,
men can do singles or doubles.
But the single sled
weighs about 50 pounds.
So it is-- there's a
part that you lie in.
Your body is sort of
in a fiberglass shell.
There are handles that you hold
onto, and then runners that go
the whole length of the sled.
Attached to that on the bottom
are steels, and they are--
there's sort of a lot of
technological espionage
in the sport, so
people are always
trying to see what other
countries are doing.
And when I was on the team--
and it's definitely still true
today--
our coach would make the sleds.
So, everything.
So from the fiberglass
to the runners.
The steels are-- that's
probably the most
technologically-complicated
part of the sled
and the most important.
And it's really--
it's very nuanced sort
of what metals comprise the
runners and what goes fast.
And sometimes it's just
really hard to know.
You might have steels
that are made--
two made exactly the same
material at the same time,
and one will be
faster than the other.
So it's like, yes, there's
a lot of technology,
but there's also some
art to it as well.
So I had a--
one of our assistant
coaches from Italy--
one summer he said,
OK, so we think
these steels are really
fast, but what I want
you to do this summer is to--
and I'm not joking here--
bury them in your backyard
so the sun and the moon
can get on the steels, and I
think we'll go even faster.
I was like, OK.
I'll do that.
TRACY EVANS: I'll try anything.
[LAUGHING]
CAMERON MYLER: And
they were fast.
I have no idea if it was,
like, burying in the backyard.
It required a lot of sanding
to get the rust off, but--
so there's definitely a lot
of technology in the sleds.
I didn't mention
before, one part
of the training
in the summertime
is practicing the start on ice.
So in Lake Placid there's an
indoor start ramp facility.
So you can practice
the start on ice.
You go down the ramp and
then up the other side.
Because it makes a
really big difference,
sort of being on ice
versus being on wheels,
which is possible,
but you don't really
get the same sort of feel.
One of the start ramps in--
it's actually the one at the
track in La Plagne in France,
where the Olympics were in '92.
So the ramp is so steep that
when you're-- so with luge
you're sitting on the
sled at the start,
hands around the handles.
So normally you can see the
ramp, see the first curve.
This ramp-- it's so
steep, you can't see it.
So you're sitting at the
start, you can't see the ramp,
and you just see
the first curve.
OK.
I hope I'm going to go straight
down there [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
I always had to pray a little.
MIKE ABRAMS: So that
leads into my question,
which is, most of
this audience--
I don't want to assume anyone--
maybe some people have--
but most of this audience
has probably never gone down
a luge ramp at
80-plus miles an hour
or flipped multiple
times on skis.
Can you describe that
experience of being in the air?
Or when you get down that
ramp in the first curve?
CAMERON MYLER: Go ahead.
TRACY EVANS: Oh goodness.
You know-- gosh.
It is so difficult
to describe what it's
like to be 60 feet in the air.
I was actually the
first woman in the world
to do a triple-twisting
double back-flip,
and a double-twisting
triple backflip.
CAMERON MYLER: Can
you demonstrate?
TRACY EVANS: Yeah, yeah.
Not so much right here.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know-- oh my goodness.
It is-- I think, you know--
I'm scared of heights.
So if you put me on top of a--
[LAUGHTER]
I know.
Everyone says, oh my gosh.
You're an aerialist.
How can you be afraid--
but just looking out and down
is just nerve-wracking to me.
It makes my legs all weak.
But going-- you know, you're
doing something in the air.
You're coming down.
You're not focused on,
really, how high you are.
Except for you need to
get your feet under you.
But, you know, it's just that
an amazing, amazing feeling of--
you know-- like I said,
it's hard to put in words.
You're at the top of the
end run and you definitely
have to figure out how to
channel the fear in a really
positive, productive
way, otherwise
you'll never be an aerialist.
But, you know,
the adrenalin rush
that you get coming down
and doing a triple flip
and landing and skiing away--
when you're down
at the bottom, it
is such an intense amount of
emotion in all of six seconds.
And it is.
It's just amazing.
I always say this.
And I love my husband
to death, but I really
haven't found quite
something that's give me
quite the adrenaline
rush that aerials has.
[LAUGHTER]
That might be too much
information, but nonetheless.
That's the way it goes.
[LAUGHING] On to you.
CAMERON MYLER: OK.
TRACY EVANS:
[IMITATING DRUMROLL]
CAMERON MYLER: So
luge is the fastest
of all of the sledding sports.
So it's faster than bobsled.
It's faster than skeleton.
And it's actually the
only Olympic sport
times the thousandth
of a second.
So the fastest
track in the world
is Vancouver, from
the men's start
is about 97 miles an hour.
So I have not gone that fast.
I've been from the
men's start in Park City
and gone about 87 miles an hour.
So fast enough.
So if you've driven
that fast in your car,
imagine sort of that
speed lying on your back
on a fairly small sled
going down an ice track.
Some of the tracks are--
and every track is different.
So some tracks are sort
of wide open curves.
Of course you have to
steer on all of them,
but some require less steering.
So the one in Park City is a
little more like an autobahn.
It's very fast, not a ton of
steering, a really fun kind
of smooth ride down.
There are other tracks,
however, that are really
technically
difficult. And if you
don't steer in exactly
the right place at exactly
the right time, you'll crash.
So I like those tracks,
and I was good at those.
MIKE ABRAMS: Great.
So let's go to the
first Olympics,
as you both are
multi-time Olympians.
That first Olympics-- what
was the emotion when you first
qualified, and then what
was emotion at the opening
ceremonies when you were there?
Were you really excited to
be there and ready to go,
or were you really nervous
about the competition?
Kind of what was going
through your head?
CAMERON MYLER: So my first
games was in '88 in Calgary,
and that year to
qualify for the team
there were a series of
races in Lake Placid.
So I qualified.
And, it's like, you know when
you qualify it's like, OK,
I've made the Olympic team.
Super excited about that.
But it wasn't really until
I walked into the opening
ceremonies that I
thought, oh my gosh,
like, I've made
the Olympic team.
I'm here representing
the United States.
And all of-- I was
19 at my first games,
so I had spent sort of
eight years preparing
for that moment.
And with that games
I didn't really
have any particular
expectation about my finish.
Like, I didn't really
expect that I had a chance
to win a medal, so I was
really just going to do my best
and hopefully have as good
a race as I possibly could.
So that games I was ninth.
I had great runs.
I was happy with the results.
And had a few more
games after that, but--
yeah.
So it's that
moment, I think when
you walk into the
opening ceremonies
is a pretty special one.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah.
So my mine was
1994, and I was 26.
[LAUGHS] And
actually Cameron was
the flag bearer at the
1994 Olympic games,
so that's a huge honor.
And they are voted--
the flag bearer is
voted by our teammates.
So she was voted by all of us
to be the flag bearer, which
was amazing.
For me, also, my brother was
actually-- after he retired--
went on to coach the Australian
freestyle ski team in aerials.
So in 1994-- again, a family
affair, he was coaching aerials
while I was competing.
So it was-- and my
parents were over there.
So that was something that
was just obviously amazing.
And like Cameron
said, the process of--
at least for freestyle--
of qualifying for the
games is a pretty long one,
and so we didn't find
out our team until, like,
two weeks before the games.
So, yes.
That's a step.
But my mentality going into
all the Olympics as well
was to make sure that I
had a degree of difficulty
that if I won or could win--
I just put myself
in a place to win.
And that was just always--
like, the Olympics is
not a place to hold back.
So that was-- yeah.
That was just-- I mean,
Lillehammer, for sure,
was just an amazing,
amazing first games.
But I will say my
last games-- real
quick-- is that it's rare that
an Olympian gets to compete
in their own home country
during your career, let
alone your own backyard.
So I live in Park City, Utah.
So the fact that
Salt Lake City held
the 2002 Olympic
games was amazing,
and that was how I
got to end my career.
So it's been-- it
was pretty cool.
CAMERON MYLER: I thought
about going for a fifth.
[LAUGHTER]
Because '98 was my last
Olympics in Nagano, Japan.
And for that reason, because
2002 was in the United States,
I thought, oh, maybe one more.
But decided to go to
law school instead.
[LAUGHTER]
So, nearly as much fun as luge.
Although I was in Park City
because, as Tracy mentioned,
I carried the flag at
the opening ceremonies
in '94, which was a huge
honor and really humbling
to be there for the
US team and really
for everybody back home as well.
Although when I was--
each sport nominates someone
to carry the flag, and then
the team captains of
all the sports vote
on who will be elected.
And Dan Janzen and Bonni
Blair were nominated.
And I was like,
OK, so this is kind
of going to be like the Oscars.
I'm really honored to
have been nominated
in this great pool of people,
and then and then I got picked.
So I was super surprised
and really, really honored.
But in Salt Lake City
the organizing committee
invited all of the flag bearers
to come and run with the torch
from the opening ceremony
stadium to the first medal
ceremony.
And everyone who had
carried the flag from--
basically who was living
and who could come
and manage to carry the torch.
And they said, well, you're
young and in pretty good shape
and all of that.
And I was like, OK, I'm
working in a law firm
on Wall Street,
like, 20 hours a day
and I can't remember the
last time I worked out.
So when we were
running you had to run
behind the van with the
camera on you the entire time,
so I thought--
and I was like, oh my gosh,
my arm's really tired.
If I drop it, like,
should I switch hands.
Like, that's not really going
to look good, but if I drop it
that's even worse.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was all OK.
TRACY EVANS: And you're
trying not to huff and puff.
[BREATHING LOUDLY]
CAMERON MYLER: I know.
I was like, oh my gosh.
Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: So is that
more nerve-wracking,
or carrying the flag in
the opening ceremony?
CAMERON MYLER: Well,
before I walked
into the stadium at the opening
ceremonies in Lillehammer
the director of marketing
for USA luge said, oh, so
like two billion people
are watching the Olympics,
so don't trip and
fall with the flag.
I was like, really?
Like, you had to say that to me?
TRACY EVANS: You tell
me that right now?
CAMERON MYLER: I didn't.
It was all good.
MIKE ABRAMS: So Tracy
brought up a good point,
that you got to compete
in your home country,
and really hometown.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: Did you ever feel,
when you went on the road,
that you didn't get
enough practice time
or the courses were different?
Or I guess, what was that
experience being a road course?
Or was it common
practice since you
traveled throughout the year?
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
No.
You know, I think one
of the things that--
even in Cameron's sport, that's
one of the things as an athlete
you have to be able to
do, is be able to change
from site to site
from week to week,
and you have to be flexible.
You have to know how to adjust
and deal with obstacles,
and all that kind of thing.
So, not really.
I mean, that was something
throughout all our years
of training that we were
used to on a weekly basis.
Like I said, World Cup
was a different site
every single week.
So every Sunday we would
travel somewhere else
and then train a couple
of days and compete,
and do it again somewhere else.
So you just learn to adapt.
MIKE ABRAMS: What
about the tracks?
Luge tracks are very different.
CAMERON MYLER: Well, yeah.
So the luge tracks
are very different.
But I'll just
mention that when--
I made the national
team when I was 15,
and my first couple
of years on the team
there was still East Germany
and Soviet Union and Yugoslavia.
And we went to all of
those places, so it was--
I mean, it was a really great
adventure, among other things,
being on the team at that time.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
CAMERON MYLER: Food
was always a challenge.
Like, I cannot identify whatever
is on my plate right now,
so you'd always bring, like,
peanut butter and jelly with
you, just in case.
TRACY EVANS: Definitely.
CAMERON MYLER: So, yeah.
Luge tracks are definitely
very, very different from track
to track.
And the US-- we were at a
little bit of a disadvantage
because Germany has four tracks.
Germans sort of run the
International Federation,
and there tend to be
three or four World Cups
on German tracks every year.
So usually the way it
works with countries
is that, if you have a track--
US has a track--
that everyone else
wants to train on.
If you're Germany-- they have a
track people want to train on.
You might swap training times.
No one wanted to train on
the track in Lake Placid,
so it was kind of worth nothing
in sort of track time leverage.
So we ended up getting, like,
not great training times.
And with the luge
track it's about--
so luge, bobsled, and skeleton
all go on the same track.
From the top of the course some
tracks are nearly a mile long.
So most of them are concrete.
There are pipes running
throughout the entire track,
and there's a big
refrigeration plant
that pumps some ammonia
compound throughout the pipes,
and you spray water on the
track and it makes ice.
However, one thing
that the Germans
liked to do when we were
training on their tracks
was-- like, give us track time
at, like, 9 o'clock at night.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Great.
And then 6:00 o'clock
the next morning.
And then they would crank up
the refrigeration so it grows,
like, frost on the ice.
So the track would be really
slow when we were training.
And in luge,
because it's so fast
and it's timed to the
thousandth of a second--
if the track is even,
like, half a second
slow it makes a really big
difference in your timing
in how you steer.
So training-- there would be
all sorts of frost on the ice,
and then race day--
I mean, literally you
would sit on your sled
and, like, look at the ice at
the start and think, like, oh.
Like, I can see my
reflection in the ice.
It's so-- the ice would be,
like, really hard and really
smooth, and very fast.
So that was always a
little bit of a challenge.
But, like Tracy said, you adapt.
It's something that you learn
how to do as an athlete.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah.
You know, it's so
different for aerials.
It's like-- you know,
we have four jumps
and there's usually two double
kickers and two triple kickers.
And we arrived there
and they're just big,
you know, piles of snow that
we have to basically go shape.
So there's certain shapers
from different countries,
and so each jump is shaped
just a little bit different.
Sometimes people
like steep jumps.
Some people like a little
bit less at the top
so it doesn't throw you up quite
so much, it throws you out.
But everybody-- I don't know.
You know, that definitely-- we
all trained at the same time.
Everybody was very supportive.
And not that that's
not an extreme sport,
but I don't know.
There was definitely
a camaraderie
between our countries
and between everyone
to make sure that the jumps
were just right for everybody.
So, yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: Well,
you have family
that's a coach from
another country, too.
TRACY EVANS: Well, yeah.
Exactly.
That, too.
But, yeah.
CAMERON MYLER: Yeah, definitely
a little different dynamic
in luge, I think.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah, definitely.
CAMERON MYLER: And I think
the Olympics in Vancouver
are probably a pretty
good example of that.
Because-- so prior to Vancouver
the two other times Canada
hosted the Olympics-- so
Montreal in '76 and then
'88 in Calgary--
they didn't win any gold medals.
0 at home, which is really--
TRACY EVANS: Wow.
That's rare.
CAMERON MYLER: It's
really unusual.
So usually you kind of have
the home field advantage
and you're going to
win more gold medals.
Canada had not done that, so
they were determined, I think,
in Vancouver to make
sure that they won gold.
So one of the
strategies-- they funded
a lot of athletes they thought
had the chance to win medals.
And then the other strategy
was to limit access
to Olympic venues for
athletes from other countries.
So, I mean, if you are a figure
skater or a hockey player,
maybe not such a big deal
because a lot of the rinks
are fairly similar.
Maybe a little bit
different ice quality,
or it's slightly
different dimensions,
but fairly much the same.
Luge, not so much.
And that was the fastest
track in the world.
So actually, the day
before the opening
ceremonies an athlete from
Georgia died on the track.
So he had 25 runs, and I
think the average Canadian
had, like, 250.
So, yeah.
It matters.
MIKE ABRAMS: Wow.
So let's pivot to post-olympics.
CAMERON MYLER: Yes.
MIKE ABRAMS: So there's--
a lot of Olympians,
in some cases,
struggle
post-professional-athletic
career and pivoting
to a new career.
You two have done very well.
So can you tell us
what you're doing now
and talk about maybe
your foundation as well?
CAMERON MYLER: Sure.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
So-- gosh.
I retired after,
obviously, the 2000--
actually, I retired
after the '98 games,
took two years off, and
went down to California
and started a division of my
brother's sports marketing
company.
CAMERON MYLER: Oh, you went
to a warm place for two years.
I'm jealous.
TRACY EVANS: I did.
[LAUGHTER]
I needed a break.
Anyway-- yeah.
And started a
sportscasting company,
and placing athletes in
different sport production--
mainly commercial
and print stuff.
It was a great break, and
I came back, obviously,
for the 2002 games.
And then afterwards
went back to casting.
So, you know, I feel
just very fortunate.
I mean, I did finish
getting my degree.
It took me 10 years, but I
had done that while I was--
CAMERON MYLER: I beat you.
It only took me seven.
[LAUGHTER]
TRACY EVANS: I had my 10 year
high school reunion the weekend
I was walking on
my college degree.
CAMERON MYLER: That's awesome.
TRACY EVANS: But anyway--
yeah.
So I feel pretty
fortunate that I
had a pretty smooth transition.
I also was very much in the--
that's just my personality.
Like, I knew I had to have
something to move on to.
And so having a business that
was already somewhat set up
was great.
And I did that for a long
time, and still doing that.
But also along the way I
went on a volunteer trip
to my mother's
prompting, basically,
and ended up starting
a foundation called
Kids Play international.
And this really truly
is my absolute passion,
without a doubt.
And it was really this
one little boy's words.
10 years old.
His name's Thomas.
I went on a volunteer
trip, and he
said to me at the end of the
trip, I can see girls can play.
And the background to that
is that we were there--
CAMERON MYLER: In Africa.
TRACY EVANS: --in
Malawi, Africa.
Yep.
And basically, of course,
we were playing soccer,
but we also introduced some new
sports with the boys and girls
over there.
And obviously developing
countries-- girls just are not
encouraged to play sport.
So when we actually
pulled out, you
know, baseball and softball
after playing soccer
where the boys were just
absolutely aggressive
and the girls stood
there like orange cones
and wouldn't interact
very well together--
but we pulled out
baseball, softball,
and it just leveled
the playing field.
They had never picked
up a bat, never played,
never heard of the sport,
never played the sport.
And it was just--
for me to watch how differently
boys and girls were learning
side-by-side, and know
just that-- everything
that sport and the Olympic
values have taught me.
And I really came
back after that trip
and decided that I
wanted to do something
with gender equality and sport.
And so it's been about
10 years in the making.
We have a year-round
program in Rwanda, Africa,
and it's really
all about building
better relationships
between boys and girls
from a very young age.
You know, boys and girls are
so segregated in developing
countries from an early
age that it's just--
through our program
it definitely
goes from simple to
complex learning.
But it's been an
amazing, amazing journey,
and such a great way
to be able to take
everything that sport has given
me and pay it forward a bit.
MIKE ABRAMS: And you're
involved, too, in [INAUDIBLE]
CAMERON MYLER: I am an athlete
ambassador, and I've been to--
TRACY EVANS: Oh yes.
[LAUGHS]
CAMERON MYLER: I've been to
Rwanda, where our program is,
a couple of times.
And I went first in 2011
and it was really, like,
one of the best things, I think,
that I've done sort of at the--
using sport in a way
that makes a difference.
So I went back this
last summer on a trip
that was funded by a
State Department grant.
And it's amazing to sort of see
the difference that the program
has made in the community.
So not just with the kids,
but the parents and teachers
and everyone had
really great stories
of how the Let's
Play Fair program has
impacted them personally.
MIKE ABRAMS: And you're also--
you went to law school after.
CAMERON MYLER: I did.
So '98 was my last games, and
I went to law school that fall.
And I decided to
go to law school
because I had been on
the US Olympic Committee
board of directors and on
the athletes advisory council
for eight years.
And there are a lot
of lawyers in sport.
You know, NBA is
nothing but attorneys.
So it's true in
Olympic sport as well.
A lot of lawyers
practicing or working
at a sports organization.
And I thought, oh,
well, maybe that's
an interesting way to sort of
combine professional career
with my interest in sport.
I wasn't quite sure how
that was going to happen,
but it seemed like a good sort
of general direction anyway.
So I went to it went to
BC for law school, and--
AUDIENCE: Woohoo!
CAMERON MYLER: Oh, yay.
Right on.
[LAUGHTER]
And I've been in New York
since I graduated law school.
So I worked on Wall Street at
a big, big firm, Milbank Tweed,
for two years, kind of went
through the law firm boot camp.
And then I went to a
smaller Median Entertainment
boutique that had really
interesting clients.
So I worked on the last JD
Salinger copyright infringement
case.
Nike was a client.
So I mostly litigated
intellectual property cases.
While I was there I also had--
because I'd been involved
with the US Olympic Committee,
after I graduated law
school I put my name--
there was, like,
a list of lawyers
who were available to athletes
who had some kind of issues.
So I put my name on the
list, and I got a call
from an athlete who
had tested positive
for some drug called modafinil,
and-- there were actually
three or four athletes.
I represented all of them.
And so I settled that case.
And when you're a
lawyer it's like you're
learning something new all the
time, especially when you're
litigating.
So I knew, of course, the
whole drug testing routine.
But it wass-- from the
lawyer's perspective
I kind of enjoyed the process.
But at the end of that first
case one of my clients,
Chryste Gaines--
she was a two-time gold
medalist and ran on the 4
by 100 meter relay
team with Marion Jones.
You probably see
where this is going.
She was one of the athletes
who was sort of caught up
in the Balco investigation
in California.
And that ended up being
a 16-month-long sort
of made-new law in the
doping world kind of case.
So I practiced law for 10 years.
And the spring of my last
year I got a call from NYU
and they asked me to
come speak on a panel
about women in sports.
So I did that.
I went out to dinner with
the faculty afterward,
and the academic
director at the time
said, oh, we'd love you
to come teach a class.
Like, right.
In my free time,
practicing law in New York.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So actually I left my firm.
I went to Rwanda with Tracy,
and then that summer NYU--
they sent an email.
It was a Monday and
they said, would you
be interested in teaching
international sports
governance?
And I thought, well,
I know that world.
It's like the IOC and
National Olympic Committees.
And I said, great.
Yeah, I'd love to.
So I said yes to that.
And then on Friday they
called and they said,
how about sports law?
Can you teach that?
I'm like, well, I don't know.
What are the topics?
So I looked at this-- it's a
pretty broad survey course,
and a lot of the things,
like IP, I'm like, fine.
Like, I did that for 10 years.
I can certainly teach that.
But antitrust and labor
law were on the syllabus
and I said, OK, just
full disclaimer here,
I don't know anything
about these areas of law,
like, at all.
And they said, it's no problem.
You can learn it.
And I'm like, OK.
And I think that's something--
like, that's in my nature
anyway, being a luge athlete.
Like, I'm really not
afraid of anything.
So I'm like, yeah, sure.
Why not?
I can do that.
So I did.
The first semester was a
little bit of a learning curve.
International sports
governance was great.
I had terrible reviews
in my sports law class.
Like, I cried.
I'm like, oh god.
It's awful.
And I said, listen.
Like, I said to the
academic directors,
if you want to get someone else
to teach the class, totally
fine with me.
Like, I don't need
this kind of thing.
And he said, go and take
Christmas break and come back,
but I think you should
teach it one more time.
And I said, oh god.
All right.
So I came back
and I thought, OK.
And again, I think both
of us, as athletes,
like, we're very determined and
you don't get to three or four
Olympic games without
having some sense
of feeling like
you can accomplish
what you've set out to do.
So I said, OK.
I'll give it another try,
and then it was great.
And so that was seven years ago.
I'm on the full-time faculty
in the sports business program,
and I love it.
MIKE ABRAMS: Awesome.
So let's briefly talk--
the Olympics are coming
up in a couple weeks.
CAMERON MYLER: Yes.
MIKE ABRAMS: What
advice would you
give to a first-time athlete
going to their first Olympics?
CAMERON MYLER: Oh, OK.
Oh, go ahead.
TRACY EVANS: Oh gosh.
I think-- you know,
you're so obviously
focused on just your
sport, and obviously
that's what you
should be focused on,
and competing and all of that.
But I think for me it was
always about also a balance.
I could not-- at least for the
way I worked as an athlete--
I could not 24 hours a
day think about my sport.
It really did me a disservice.
And so I always like
to try to remind people
to take a little bit of--
do something else that will
take your mind off of it.
And that doesn't mean go party
outside before your event
or anything like that.
CAMERON MYLER: We
don't do that anyway.
TRACY EVANS: No, no, no.
Nobody did that.
But anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
But-- or spend too much
time in the cafeteria.
That was the big thing.
Everyone said, do
not spend so much
time in the cafeteria
inside the Olympic village.
Because that was just the
biggest social place ever.
But anyway-- it is--
you really should just be able
to take a little bit of time
away from your sport.
And so balance your
Olympic experience.
And it's OK to, like I said,
go out and enjoy yourself.
Mostly after your
event, but even
leading up to it, to have
a good balance of, I think,
just mental--
you know, the physical
side of it, at that point,
you're not Russian--
I mean, yes, you're maintaining
whatever you need to do,
but you're not looking to,
like, get a major workout
in to hope that your
quads are stronger
for a landing at that point.
But it's really a mental--
it's such a mental
point at that.
I always say, after the
Olympics people say, like,
gosh how do you feel
after your event's over,
after the Olympics are over?
And I literally
felt like I had held
my breath for about four years.
And so when you
finally were done,
the exhaustion is
really hard to describe.
But it's like you finally get
to breathe again before you just
start ramping it up again.
But still, you do.
It's exhausting.
So my advice is
just to make sure
that you give yourself
a little bit of a break.
CAMERON MYLER: So
I would say to try
not to be distracted
by everything
that's going on at the games.
Because-- Tracy, I'm
sure, would agree--
it is such a different
experience than any other race
that you go to.
So if you're on
the World Cup tour
you're there with
only luge athletes,
and everybody goes
from track to track
and you see the same people
at training and in the race.
And in that context with the
team, you stay in a hotel,
you eat all of your meals
together at the same time,
there's a room where
you keep your sleds,
where you can work
on your sleds.
You get your sled, you
go put it in the van,
you drive to the track.
It's pretty-- you know,
it's pretty simple.
At the Olympics it's an
entirely different thing.
So you're staying at
the village with people
from what I last read
for Pyeongchang, there
are 93 countries right now
sending athletes to the games.
So you're in a village with
athletes from dozens and dozens
of countries.
You are not eating necessarily--
where the dining hall is maybe
not right where you stay, and
where your equipment is stored
is someplace else.
So logistically it's
much more complicated.
And, I mean, there's
so much going on.
TRACY EVANS: Media.
You're definitely
being pulled on that.
CAMERON MYLER: Yeah.
Definitely.
Media requests,
press conferences.
And so there's a lot that
can sort of draw you,
I think, outside of your zone
of focus during the games.
Luge-- I felt like we
were always really lucky
because the race is at the
beginning of the Olympics
every time.
So the opening
ceremonies are on Friday.
Men's singles race on
Saturday and Sunday.
The women are on
Monday and Tuesday.
Doubles on Wednesday,
and then you're done.
So it's like six days
into the games, there
are 11 more days to
go and you can go
and you can go-- so you go
see your teammates compete,
and then you figure
out which sponsors
are having the best parties.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
CAMERON MYLER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
See, for aerials--
CAMERON MYLER:
After a competition.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Moguls was always first and
aerials was always second week.
So we actually, for
Nagano, did not even
show up for opening ceremonies.
We were at a training
camp before we came.
So we came well into the
first week of the games.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
And there are.
There's definitely a lot
of distractions, for sure.
I always found it so nice--
like you said-- you know,
when we actually got to
our site it felt like home.
Because you're
obviously-- that's
the familiarity of
your sport being there.
And you're right,
nothing can prepare you
for when you look down--
well, it's different probably
at the top of a track.
But for us at the
top of a hill, you
look out and see the entire--
all the spectators.
And it's massive.
Like, we obviously
have had spectators
at World Cups and
world championships.
Nothing was like the first time.
I was like, oh.
Oh, wow.
OK.
Let's not focus on that.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
Let's just turn around and just
think about what we're doing,
not everyone down there.
In fact, this is a
very funny story.
In 2002 in Deer Valley
where our site was
I was at the top of
the hill just training,
and I could just hear
somebody down at the bottom
really, like, just
annoying, yelling something.
I was just like,
god, who is that?
Land, ski, do a practice jump,
come down, back up, same thing.
Come down again.
I'm really, like, wow, I
don't know why this is really
irritating me.
It was my family.
That's why.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, yeah.
It was my family.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
I went over, found my phone,
called my brother and said,
you need to go over there
and tell them to be quiet.
I was like, oh my gosh,
that is really annoying.
So it's amazing that that--
you heard that, but
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TRACY EVANS: Yes.
Yes.
Exactly.
So anyway.
MIKE ABRAMS: So do you want to
open up to audience questions?
There's microphones
on both sides.
CAMERON MYLER: And maybe
we'll just mentioned
that we're both going to
the Olympics in Pyeongchang.
So I am an arbitrator on the
court of arbitration for sport,
and I'm one of six
arbitrators who
will decide any doping case
that comes up at the Olympics.
So I'll be over there for
the whole time doing that.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah.
CAMERON MYLER: I think
all of the Russian cases
will be taken care of by then.
TRACY EVANS: [LAUGHS]
CAMERON MYLER: And
Tracy's going to be there
as well, getting an award.
TRACY EVANS: Well, yeah.
MIKE ABRAMS: So I have a
fun question while people--
if people want to
start lining up.
My fun question is, what
is the craziest, wildest,
family-friendly story of things
you saw during the Olympic
village--
in the Olympics village?
TRACY EVANS: Oh, goodness.
Family-friendly?
Hm.
Wow.
Goodness.
Hm.
Well--
CAMERON MYLER: I don't
know that I have any.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah?
Yeah.
CAMERON MYLER: I'm a lawyer.
I have no stories.
TRACY EVANS: You
have no stories.
Yeah, exactly.
No.
You know, I think just with--
the Olympic village really--
it has everything and anything.
If you wanted to go
get your hair done,
go get your nails done.
You know, they had
a disco, a bar--
there was no alcohol in sight.
CAMERON MYLER: OK,
I do have a story.
[LAUGHTER]
TRACY EVANS: OK.
CAMERON MYLER: Speaking of bars.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
There was no alcohol
on campus, was there?
CAMERON MYLER: Well,
you finish your story.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, yeah.
I don't know.
It was just very much
an all-inclusive.
But it was just a very
unique all-inclusiveness--
CAMERON MYLER: Experience.
TRACY EVANS: Experience.
Yes.
CAMERON MYLER: So
in 1992 the Olympics
were in France in Albertville,
and the main village
was in the city of Albertville.
But none of the venues
were very close to town,
so you had to drive basically
two hours to any venue,
and you'd have to drive down a
valley and then up a mountain.
And then to get
to any other venue
you'd have to go back
down the mountain, back
down the valley to
Albertville and then out
in some other direction.
So at that games we--
the luge athletes
and bobsled athletes
were together in a sort
of separate "village,"
and it was a Club
Med in La Plagne
and there was beer and wine.
TRACY EVANS: Oh goodness.
CAMERON MYLER: Like, on tap.
Well, it was--
they were treated--
it was like the sort of Club Med
practices were still going on.
So they'd drive around
with the cheese carts.
And I think after maybe,
like, the first five
days of the games
maybe we drank, like,
all of the wine and beer and ate
all of the cheese or something.
But they're like, OK, maybe we
need to cut all of that off.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah.
Exactly.
MIKE ABRAMS: We have
an audience question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
so much for coming.
I'm curious, just given
how intense the training
is between games, how
athletes support themselves,
sort of year to year to year, as
their careers sort of stretch.
CAMERON MYLER: Yeah.
Great question.
So I was on the national
team for 14 years.
And luge had, and
still has, some--
there's like a race
incentive program.
So you can, depending on where
you finish in World Cup races,
win money that comes from
the US luge association.
So I did well enough that--
I got enough money that I
supported myself through that.
And there were also
grants available,
like through the US
Olympic Committee.
So I feel like I was fairly
fortunate in that respect,
that I didn't have
to work that much.
I did some at school, but
otherwise I didn't really
have that really big
challenge, I think,
of sort of balancing work and
training at the same time.
So I think some athletes
sort of survive that way.
Some have sponsorships
that help support them.
And then others, I think--
I think it can be a really big
challenge to support yourself.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Same here.
I mean, we would have ski
sponsors, boot sponsors,
had gear sponsors.
So you would set up a
retainer with your sponsor,
and then a victory
schedule depending
on how well you did
throughout the year,
or if you made the
world championship
team you get a bonus for that,
or obviously an Olympic team,
and all of that.
And also for us the way-- you
were on A team, B team, C team,
so you would get some funding
from your federation as well,
cover flight and travel and
training expenses, basically.
But having said that-- exactly.
What's really difficult,
I think, in general
with sport is when you're trying
to come up through the ranks.
It's such a double-edged sword
because you can't get sponsors
without results.
Well, you can't get
results until you actually
start competing.
And so it is so
difficult, I think,
for upcoming athletes to be able
to-- unless you have parents
that can finance it--
you do.
You have to get a second job.
Eric Bergoust, gold medalist
in 1998, lived out of his car,
ate peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches
for I-don't-know-how-many
summers and years.
I mean that-- you
just wanted to do it.
One good thing is, the
Olympic training centers now--
you know, Lake Placid
and Colorado Springs,
depending on your sport--
you can go there and
live and have that.
But again, you have to also
have worked your way up
to a certain point.
So it's difficult. Yeah.
It's not always an easy--
unfortunately you probably lose
some really incredible talent
just due to lack of support.
CAMERON MYLER: And I
think in Olympic sport
most athletes don't
have really big sponsors
or a ton of financial support.
So, like, the Michael
Phelps of the world
are very few and far
between in Olympic sports.
So most of us do it
because we love it.
TRACY EVANS: We love it.
Yeah.
The shelf life of
even a gold medalist
these days is so
short, especially now
with the Olympics
being every two years.
So as soon as the winter
games are over, boom,
you've got maybe a month
to kind of really--
if you want a medal and
do everything with media
that you can, try to
reap those benefits.
But then sponsors are
looking at the next Olympics
already right after that.
So again, there's
clearly exceptions
to those rules for sure, but
the majority of Olympians--
you got to love what you do.
You got to love the sport.
You got to love it.
You're not going to-- even
if you are a gold medal,
does not mean you
are set for life.
MIKE ABRAMS: Do you have
an audience question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have two questions.
The first is actually
related to what you were just
talking about with this
shift from being every two
years as winter and
summer versus when
they were concurrent, like,
how you saw things change.
And the other is, can
you talk about your day
to day or, like, a week--
what would a week look
like with training?
And how did your
training groups change
as you went from one
Olympics to the next?
CAMERON MYLER: So I kind of
went through the transition
from when the summer and winter
games were in the same year
to being staggered every two.
So 1992 was the last year
that summer and winter
were in the same year, and
then winter was again in '94.
So normally-- which,
it sounds great.
Like, I had four
Olympics in 10 years.
But actually it was a
really quick turnaround,
because normally
after a games you've
kind of got a year
where you might
experiment with your
equipment and try
a new sled or some
different things that,
because you've got some time
leading up to the next games.
TRACY EVANS: Recover.
CAMERON MYLER: But
after '92 it was like,
OK, we're actually-- that next
season you were qualifying
for the Olympics again already.
So I think though that--
for winter sports
particularly I think
it's good that the
games are every two
years because the
media can focus on--
give as much attention,
almost, to winter as to summer.
So I think that in
general it's positive.
And on the training front--
so it's different sort of in
the winter and the summer,
sort of in season
and out of season.
But in season usually we would
be at a track for no longer
than a week.
So if you're in the
World Cup season,
the race ends on Sunday, you
pack up all of your stuff.
And luge-- like, the
equipment is heavy.
And one time we
were in the airport
and there was a
scale in the floor
and we actually put
all of the stuff on.
So we had to weigh
it, and always we're
paying extra baggage fees.
And we literally had
a ton of equipment.
So you had to pack that up
every Sunday into the cargo van,
and then you drive
to the next place.
So usually then Monday,
like, afternoon you'd
be on the track.
You'd train twice
a day on the track,
get a physical workout in, work
on your sled, take a nap, eat.
So you're pretty
much in a routine.
Summertime you might be--
I was at Dartmouth a lot of
the time, or in Lake Placid,
and that's more,
like, in the gym
doing start practice and
more physical training.
TRACY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah.
So my first Olympics was '94,
and my first year on the team
was '91.
So your having been in Olympics
and then have to turn around--
I did not experience that.
But I was actually very
happy when I got on the team
that the Olympics were
coming again in two years.
So for me--
Yeah.
And I agree.
I think it's good
for winter Olympics
to be its own year,
so to speak, because I
do think that when they were
concurrent that summer always
kind of overshadowed winter.
So anyway, I think
that it's a good thing.
So training-- yes.
Gosh.
For training for aerials,
our summer time training
is definitely far
more intense than it
is when we're on the road.
Once you're on the road
and competing week to week
it's more of a maintenance-type
of mentality, so to speak.
But our summer training
definitely was pretty intense.
We would get up and have a
couple hours on the trampoline.
We'd do a couple
hours water ramping.
We'd have lunch.
We'd go to the gym for
another couple hours,
and sometimes even a trampoline
session at night time.
So it kind of--
inside the gym, so to speak.
But, so-- yeah.
And you were just really trying
to-- you would definitely--
I think it depends on where
you are in your career.
Obviously if you're
just starting off
and you're a rookie,
you're really
trying to do a lot more jumps
and qualifying a lot of jumps.
As you're becoming more
of a veteran on the team
you're trying to have a
different type of training.
It's quality over
quantity, basically.
So that's kind of how it
worked in the summertime.
Everyone kind of had more
of an individualized plan
depending on what you were
doing with your jumps.
But then the winter, pretty
much what Cameron said.
I mean, it's week
to week traveling.
You'd get into a site on Monday,
you would work on the jumps,
you would hopefully at least
have one day of training
on the jumps.
Sometimes with weather
you didn't even
get to train on the jump
until the day you competed,
which was never fun.
But usually you have at least
one or two days of training,
you'd compete, pack up,
move on to the next place.
CAMERON MYLER: And
probably one thing
I would add to this for
both of us would be,
maybe later in your career you
might spend some time in sports
medicine doing some rehab
on your various joints.
[LAUGHTER]
I had four knee surgeries
and one on each shoulder,
so it definitely takes
a toll on the body.
TRACY EVANS: For a skier I
actually have both my ACLs,
which is very rare.
So I've been--
I feel like I got out of
the sport pretty unscathed.
Eh, you know, I definitely
have some things, but--
MIKE ABRAMS: Well,
Tracy, Cameron,
thank you for being here.
CAMERON MYLER:
Thank you so much.
MIKE ABRAMS: Thanks,
everyone, for coming.
And that's it.
TRACY EVANS: Awesome.
Thanks everybody.
CAMERON MYLER: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]